because you know what's coming now is
the flash mobs now i've i uh warned of
this uh many many uh moons ago
i was on the record talking i think
about flash mobs i'm unsure
now the flash mob is not nearly as fun
as it sounds what it is is a gang of 20
or 30
people and they run into nordstroms
which would be fine because no one cares
about faceless
corporations like nordstroms right
kind of but they they beat the people in
the nordstrom so that's not good so the
flash mobs come in and they're not you
know a lot of people try to make them
out to be like fun
you know theatrical events
where people are just kind of like
striking a death blow to capitalism by
grabbing a few handbags but they're
beating the people at nordstrom's
they're attacking them they're hurting
security guards they're hurting people
that work at nordstrom's it's not good
and seth rogen thinks it's good seth
rogen thinks it's good and seth rogen do
you know what he did recently
seth rogen drove
a few people over to casey neistat's
house to rob his car
seth rogen is facing backlash after
downplaying youtuber casey nastat's
experience with car theft uh casino stat
has children he had uh a pinata or
something in the back of his car
something like that party favors
decorations so yeah
all right so
somebody robbed them yeah here i got the
thread right here and and casey was uh
unhappy and he tweeted so our cars got
robbed this morning because los angeles
is a crime riddled third world [ __ ]
of a city
well that's a lot but hey
he goes but tremendous appreciation and
gratitude to the hard-working officers
at
lapd west who not only arrested the
[ __ ] but they got all of our
stolen goods back so that's casey
neistat taking the terribly popular
position of uh calling out la for being
crime-ridden and then also saying hey uh
thanks to the cops which a lot of people
do not love
hey thanks to the cops and then seth
rogen says
um
dude i've lived here for 20 years you're
nuts haha it's lovely here don't leave
anything valuable in it in your car
right in it
it's called living in a big city so seth
rogen's whole point is like hey man
relax
and casey goes i can still be mad though
right i feel so violated
seth rogen goes you can be mad but i
guess i don't personally view my car as
an extension of myself
and i've never really felt violated any
of the 15 or so times my car was broken
into once a guy accidentally left a cool
knife in my car so if it keeps happening
you might get a little treat so seth
rogen is high as usual right he's always
high right that's his thing yeah he's a
drug addict he's like a weird company he
likes drugs there's nothing wrong with
it he's addicted to drugs probably
i i mean there's nothing wrong with that
but that seems to be what his thing is
right he sells weed he's
so he like doesn't care about people
right seth rogen would be robbing cars
if he wasn't an actor probably that's
kind of what this comes down to seth
rogen's like hey man i'd be breaking
into your car if i wasn't uh uh an actor
who was a funny guy
and seth rogen's made some great movies
but
you know i think seth rogen's kind of
like i i
um really like
empathize with whoever stole your
daughter's
party decorations out of your car
because frankly i would be doing
something similar
had i if i wasn't a
multi-multi-multi-millionaire
he said this kind of example of a guy
who seems to have run he's run so far to
the left he's in self-parody he's it's
not even real anymore like he's unable
to
make a point that doesn't descend into
some type of parody because he's so on
another planet that i understand people
going casey you're overstating it la is
not a third world [ __ ]
most of it might be some of it is but
not all of it right you can't say all of
it right
and i understand like says rogan being
like hey man that was a little bit much
but then cedric would be like i don't
view my car as an extension of myself
well what if someone put a gun in your
head and made you get out of it
and they stole it
because here's the deal
seth rogen doesn't need to view his car
as an extension of himself because he's
rich
see rich people don't care about cars
because they can get new ones
they can uh you know have a driver pick
them up it doesn't really matter but if
all you owned is a card now certain
people all they are now this may
surprise seth rogen i'm sure it wouldn't
i'm sure he knows but all certain people
own is a card now casey neistat is not
one of those people
he owns more than this is why it's tough
right yeah sure it's tough it's like the
comics who are commenting on me and
michael che it's like two guys with a
lot of money upset at each other and
then some guy eating rats being oh one
day he's gonna win
[Applause]
it's
some people just have a car so when your
car is broken into to some people it's
not nothing
it's something
i remember when i when all i had was my
car and i would do cocaine and get in
accidents and it's upsetting
when you are coked out of your face and
drunk and you smash up your car and it's
all you own it's a big deal so i can
only imagine how i would have felt if
someone broke into it because i was
devastated uh at uh when i smashed uh
totaled five cars and that was very sad
but seth has to understand that that not
everybody has a real estate portfolio
and
projects they care about
you know seth is lucky like we're lucky
we get to do something we like we have
projects
and people care about projects and
things you get to see come to fruition
things you can start and pour your mind
and body and soul into and then and then
love and and and curate and then see
them go from nothing to something
they're movies and books and whatever
and uh not everyone has that some people
literally just have a chevy cruze
and they they s and they're proud of it
and they work their ass off for it so if
somebody walks by and smashes it and
grabs their [ __ ] out of it they're gonna
be upset